hey this is presh tolwalker let's play a
card game every card has a letter on one
side and a number on the other side
in front of you are four cards d k three
and seven
the cards are manufactured according to
a rule
every card that has a d on one side has
a three on the other
the question is which card or cards need
to be turned over to check if the rule
has been followed
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so what's the correct answer
you do need to check the d card but you
also need to check the seven card
you do not need to check the K card or
the three card
if you didn't solve this don't worry
you're in good company
only about 10 percent of people
correctly solve this
this task was developed in the 1960s by
the psychologist Peter Wasson the wayson
selection task has been replicated
thousands of times in the decades
following and still only about 10
percent of people correctly solved this
why is it so difficult
to answer that let's go over why you
need to check only dn7
let's analyze each card individually
we'll start with d
the rule states that every card that has
a d on one side has a three on the other
this can be translated into the logical
statement if D then three
so naturally we need to check a card
that has a d does have a three on the
other side
so we have the set of cards that have a
d on one side and that's contained
within the set of cards that have a
three on the other side so definitely we
need to check the d card
so if the D card has a three on the
other side then we know the rule is
being followed but if it has some other
number we know the rule is not being
followed we definitely need to check the
d card
what about the card with the K we know
if D then three
but if k then what we don't know it
could be that every card that is a k has
a 3 on the other side it could be that
some cards with the K have a three on
the other side or kn3 could be mutually
exclusive events we don't know from the
rule if D then three
so if we flipped over the K card and we
found a three that wouldn't have
anything to do with the rule and if we
flipped over the K card and found a four
that again would have nothing to do with
the rule we don't need to check the K
Card
now what about the card with the three
this is a little bit more tricky to
understand
so we know if D then three
but if three then what we don't know we
know that all cards with the D have a
three on the other side but we don't
know exactly what's going on with three
if we flip over the card with three and
we find it does not have a d on the
other side that would be fine that would
not violate the rule if we flip it over
and it does have a d that would also be
fine
so no matter what we don't need to check
the card that has a three
now what about the card that has a seven
so if D then three
so let's take a look at this consider
the entire sample space and consider the
area not three
so if we have not three that will
definitely be not D this is the
contrapositive of if D then three
now 7 is a number that's not three so if
seven then not D so we definitely do
need to check the seven card we want to
make sure it does not have a d
if we flip over the seven card and it's
not a d that would be fine but if we
flip it over and there is a d this would
violate the rule because we found a card
with d on one side that does not have a
three on the other so we definitely do
need to check the seven card
so to summarize we do need to check the
d card we do need to check the seven
card but we do not need to check the K
or the three cards this is the correct
answer and only about 10 percent of
people correctly solve the question
now what about mathematicians
at the University of Warwick Matthew
Inglis and Adrian Simpson tried the
wayson selection task on mathematicians
who are trained in logical thinking you
might think that mathematicians solve
this problem 100 of the time correctly
that's not what they found so they
tested math students math staff and
history students now to summarize this
table overall 94 of all people asked did
pick D so as generally understood that
you do need to check the d card that's a
good thing
now what about the correct answer of D
and seven
so there were incorrect answers given by
71 percent of math students 57 of math
staff and 92 percent of History students
which resembles the general population
of the waste and selection task
so what does this tell you
overall mathematicians scored very
poorly on this task given that logic is
a central part of studying mathematics
even mathematicians find this question
to be difficult
so where were the common mistakes many
people pick D or D3 alone
other people thought of DK and seven
some people thought of picking all of
the cards which would actually be fine
if you have an employee you say I want
to make sure the cards are correct it
would actually be fine if someone
checked all of the cards but this is not
the correct answer to the puzzle
so if only 10 percent of people are
logical how can Society function at all
let's put this problem in a little
different context imagine every single
card represents a person
on one side of the card is the beverage
the person is drinking and on the other
side of the card is the person's age
so you're given four cards
beer coffee 25 and 16. suppose there's a
rule that a person drinking beer must be
over 20 years old
which card or cards need to be turned
over to check if the role has been
followed
so this problem people find much easier
if you think about it for a moment you
of course need to check the card which
has a beer to make sure that the other
side is a number that's 20 or more
you also need to check the 16 card to
make sure that the 16 year old is not
drinking beer
what about the coffee card it doesn't
matter how old the person is who's
drinking coffee that has nothing to do
with the rule
and what about the 25 card well the
person is 25 can drink whatever that
person wants so you don't need to check
that card
they found that 75 percent of people
correctly solve this version of the
puzzle
but if you look at this puzzle and the
original puzzle they are logically
exactly the same puzzle so why do people
solve one puzzle at a much higher rate
than they solve the other puzzle
many times we incorrectly think about
the world as logical and illogical
people
but logical thinking is a skill that we
can work on
if you practice bodybuilding you're
going to build muscles if you work on
fashion you're going to look better if
you work on chess skills you're going to
play chess better similarly if you work
on logical thinking and problem solving
skills you're going to be better at
solving logical questions
so do yourself a favor and try watching
One video every single day about logical
thinking and problem solving
you'll improve to the point that even
mathematicians will be envious of your
skills
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time